dans ce bureau de presse au cœur d'un
petit village belge les gagnants
appellent la gérante les uns après les
autres pour vérifier la bonne nouvelle
félicitations on dirait que vous n'en
revenez pas
143 millions d'euros remportés par un
groupe de 165 habitants tous avaient
joué ici les mêmes chiffres ensemble le
gain sera divisé équitablement plus de
800.000 euros par personne pendant une
heure finalement exactement hier en
début de soirée Bernard Arnault a été en
tête du classement du magazine forb
classement en temps réel qui tient
compte des cours de bourse le PDG
français de LVMH et sa famille
détenaient alors 185 milliards de
dollars ce qu'il plaçait juste devant
Elon Musk victime lui d'un être recul de
l'action de Tesla et puis finalement
vers 19h30 Elon Musk a repris sa place
d'un cheveu devant Bernard Arnault
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous listez les causes d'un divorce
c'est très intéressant qu'on a fait un
petit tour de table avant que l'émission
commence on a remarqué que tout le monde
se trompait la cause principale c'est
l'infidélité évidemment ça reste ça ça
reste il y a pas d'ouverture
ces trois copains ils décident de parler
de leur nana tu vois
la mienne elle a des cuisses de
grenouilles alors je la saute
le deuxième mini tu as quand même de la
chance il y a pas la mienne elle a une
culotte de cheval alors je la monte
hôpital 3e qui dit mais attends
je la trompe alors l'égoïsme du
partenaire arrive en deux 22 % des
demandes de divorce et le mauvais
caractère 15% et alors après il y a des
raisons plus obscures qui prête presque
plus à sourire oui la dernière notamment
qui est risqué listé pardon c'est celle
de la place des beaux-parents
et c'est quand même la cause de 10 %.
cette affection cette admiration j'avais
envie qu'on s'en dix un mot vous allez
comprendre
c'est par devant oui
juste en dessous
dans les fêtes les Belges les femmes
belges à la fin des soirées elles
s'asseyent sur les barbecues
[Applaudissements]
avec un trouble neurologique très rare
appeler en anglais Steve personnel
qui a été environ une personne sur un
million
on ne sait pas encore tout de cette
maladie rare
mais on sait maintenant que c'est la
cause d'espace musculaire dont je
souffre la manière dont l'utilisation
forcenait des téléphones portables par
les jeunes par exemple les modifier à
terme et que ça soit transmissible
génétique ces dernières années il y a eu
plusieurs études très inquiétantes pas
toutes sérieuses sur le sujet certaines
nous prédisent un troisième œil ou un
énorme pouce un très moche très laid je
voudrais vous montrer un de ces humains
du futur ce sont des artistes là des
artistes de la 3D qui ont extrapolé
vraiment exagéré des travaux
scientifiques pour imaginer Mindy Mendy
elle est gratinée vous allez le voir où
trouver Vincent un désert de James
Stewart qui était oui acteur fétiche dit
Cox
une élégance et un flegme comme ça et
une façon aussi de de d'avoir un petit
temps de retard mais oui mais sur un peu
décalé bancal qui qui a de l'esprit quoi
[Rires]
sais pas quoi pourra ressembler dans
quelques siècles notre colonne
vertébrale s'est courbée notre Nuxe
c'est épaissi musclé également pour
tenir notre tête penchée sur nos
téléphones les chercheurs appellent ça
un techneck donc la nuque de la
technologie la main aussi s'est tordu
pour être en position texto et j'ajoute
qu'on aurait une espèce de deuxième
paupière transparente pour filtrer la
lumière Dieu de téléphone je précise
encore une fois que c'est plus de l'art
que de que de la science ça arrive dans
les écrans c'est vous bien sûr mais sous
un autre jour avec Bernard Lama et oui
photos quand même légendaire
l'image du jour la conférence de presse
hier au mondiale de l'équipe de Brésil
invité surprise à la table comme ça
tranquille ça c'est le sourire du joueur
Vinicius et il est là il est là le petit
matou regardez alors on valide on valide
pas forcément la manière dont il est
projeté au sol donc on se demande
pourquoi ce chat était en conférence de
presse on aura peut-être la réponse avec
Cécile Bartoli dans le journal du
Mondial dans quelques minutes ça va bien
les amis
et voici le bandit masqué surnom du
[ __ ] laveur aux États-Unis l'un de ses
attaqué au début du mois à la petite
Riley 5 ans une agression rare captée
par des images de vidéo surveillance qui
font le tour des réseaux sociaux alerté
par l'écrit la mère de la fillette s'est
débarrassée de cet animal classé
nuisible non sans mal Riley et sa maman
ont été légèrement blessés le [ __ ]
laveur lui est en fuite ça suffit les
mauvaises nouvelles comment ça va ange
avec des blagues comme ça ça peut que
aller bien oubliez gala et son
nouvelle l'hymne des Bleus vient de
sortir il est signé Gilbert Montagné
[Musique]
en équipe de France
tu es magique
et
ça fera une troisième étoile peut l'air
emporter trois Coupes du monde